joining us now former Trump campaign
aide Carter page himself also the hills
John Solomon John we have one other
little piece here and the FBI we know
that Andrew McCabe is under a criminal
investigation now he's also being
investigated for leaks as it relates to
general Flynn and by the way those leaks
we knew from the get-go were illegal
because that was we all know
surveillance on masking that never
should have been never should have
happened or leaked in the first place
yeah there's some new documents out
tonight Sean the FBI released them on
their public information site the vault
and they reveal for the first time that
there was an investigation of comments
allegedly made by the Deputy Director
Andrew McCabe about President Trump and
Flynn we don't know anything more than
that we know that they list
McCabe as a witness in the investigation
not a subject but it's the first time
we've heard anything about this and I
think that's an important thing also
today the Senate Intelligence security
chief pled guilty to his kind of making
lying about his contacts with the media
so this leak fest that was going on
believable starting to be exposed little
by little yeah we now have the entire
puzzle framed in and we're filling in
all the pieces and it's pretty clear
what happened
Carter look you're in the center of all
this we know that four or five the
judges the fraud was committed on them
the bulk of information was that phony
dossier that even we know that
Christopher Steele wouldn't stand by now
you got rod Rosen Stein he's refusing to
testify under oath you know we can't get
Glenn Simpson to testify under oath we
can't get the 302s the gang of eight
information or the FISA applications
that were all subpoenaed and supposed to
be coming out you're suing the DNC and
who else
Perkins cuy and a few of our partners
yes well I mean I got to imagine here
you're gonna be a really wealthy guy
because what they did to you if wheat
you all your Fourth Amendment
protections or stomped on this isn't
political even in any way Carter Sean it
but it's also you know it goes beyond
any damages or any you know financial
aspects I mean there has just been so
many lies as you're alluding to
and you look at the damage it did to our
democratic systems and you know our
institutions and government back in 2016
now I'm just trying to get some justice
in terms of getting some disclosure if
you look at some of the prior dodgy
dossier cases like mr. gubarev he's the
one that actually got some of the
biggest information out there that you
know Senate Judiciary Committee and
House Intelligence Committee have been
facing a lot a lot of things on
interview their association you you also
helped your government you would debrief
after traveling abroad freely with the
intelligence community FBI CIA and Evon
indicted you all right real quick in the
last few seconds we have John what is
next here and where are these D
classifications and where are the
unredacted materials what are they
coming yeah I think they're being slow
walked again Sean and it's frustrating
for all of us who really want the public
to benefit from the truth I think you're
not going to see them but stay tuned
later this week I'll have a story
that'll bring a whole new character into
the Russia tale I would trust you
because you've been breaking news along
with our team for 18 months thank you
both